[Musique]
[Musique]
et
on
enfin
[Musique]
en
on
[Musique]
en
faux
[Musique]
ans
en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
en
frans
[Musique]
ans
voilà vous venez de de faire la
connaissance de charlie son sein un
épagneul breton pour des cpr garden de
mon presque huit ans maintenant
mais bon ben voilà vous avez vu un petit
peu comment comment on communique
ensemble comment comment on joue mais
charlie en fait ça n'a pas toujours été
son prénom et on n'a pas toujours vécu
ensemble non plus je n'ai rencontré
quand il ya presque six ans dans un
refuge à montpellier à l'époque son nom
s'était garé où il faisait il pesait 25
kg aujourd'hui ils ont fait 17 et il
était arrivé là bas un jour avant à
cause du décès de son maître
personne n'avait voulu le garder donc
voilà il attendait derrière les barreaux
et moi même je venais de perdre une
ancienne amie et j'avais vraiment besoin
d'un nouveau repère en fait d'un nouveau
compagnon de route et je sais pas
pourquoi mais au milieu des quelques 250
chiens qui étaient présents là bas j'ai
j'ai su que c'était lui plus qu'un autre
en fait j'ai senti qu'il se passait
quelque chose entre nous y avait un truc
que j'obtiens avait pas ont déjà il
avait un désintérêt total envers ma
personne qu'il avait beaucoup de graisse
sur les côtes
et ça marche en laisse ça ressemblait
plus à un attelage de chiens de traîneau
mais bon je les gelées et mais quand
même et j'ai décidé de de passer un bout
de ton de ma vie avec lui alors au début
ce n'était pas facile j'ai eu beaucoup
de mal à m'attacher à lui en fait
quelque part je lui en voulais d'être là
et d'avoir pris la place de cette chaîne
que j'avais plus c'était un peu idiot
vous c'est moi qui avais quand même
choisi de vous qui viennent dans ma vie
mais finalement je regrettais presque
mon choix et puis au fur et à mesure des
années des mois j'ai bien été obligé
d'apprendre à l'est mais j'ai été obligé
d'apprendre à le connaître
elle comprendra lui a enseigné des
choses et puis lui m'enseigner des
choses aussi alors petit à petit tous
les deux on a créé des choses on a
imaginé
on a forgé un petit peu un lien et puis
on a on a commencé à danser
vous l'avez vu mais pas comme ça au
début mais on a commencé dans notre
salon de la maison familiale et puis
après dans mon premier appartement
montpellier avant j'étais libre 1
j'avais 18 ans j'étais tout content
et puis on l'a on a continué comme ça on
a fait quelques erreurs on a préparé
quelque chose et puis on notre petit
salon d'appartements on est arrivés
jusqu'aux la grande scène du studio 107
1 saint denis où l'on tourne la france a
un incroyable talent et je crois que je
remercierai jamais assez
mon ami qu'elle a pour toutes les choses
qui m'a fait vivre et non l'une d'entre
elles c'est aussi d'être là aujourd'hui
pour vous parler alors après j'ai pas
que ce chien là maintenant j'ai d'autres
chiens qui sont arrivées dans ma vie
j'ai cody d'ajka et puis orient
le petit dernier cd chiens qui sont
complètement différents et avec qui la
relation elle-même est complètement
différente
en fait ça dépend du passé dajka par
exemple ten feet malinoise qui a été
récupérée de maltraitance donc elles
avaient les oreilles découpé et puis
plein d'autres blessures physiques et
psychologiques
cody c1 les paris sont ouverts
un mélange de plein de choses avec un
strabisme
c'est un grand gamin dans sa tête et lui
il a été trouvé petit elle par la
fourrière il n'a jamais été réclamée et
orion c'est mon premier chiot tout neuf
c'est un petit beauceron de six mois est
de 32 kg en fait j'avais hâte d'avoir un
chiot est de voir les différences entre
l'établissement d'un chien adulte que je
récupère déjà adulte qui a connu
beaucoup de choses bonnes comme
mauvaises avant
et un chiot pour qui j'étais plus ou
moins la première qui était vraiment le
c'est la seule chose qu'il voulait
c'était d'avoir une relation avec
quelqu'un et finalement je me suis rendu
compte que selon chiens selon son passé
c'était pas forcément différent entre
entre un chien adulte et plus auront par
exemple
cody donc mon grand croisé lui et elle
était vraiment il voulait trouver
quelqu'un il n'était il avait juste il
attendait que ça il était déjà prêt
destiné à trouver une famille il était
encore très jeune dans sa tête lui pour
parle par exemple c'est un chien que
j'ai jamais tenus en laisse en balade
même le premier soir à la maison j'ai
senti qu'en fait ils avaient ils
n'avaient aucune intention partir loin
de moi il avait pendant il n'avait pas
envie de se défaire de moi il n'avait
pas besoin d'une corde pour être pour
être lié à moi alors que d'ajka ça a été
beaucoup plus compliquée elle elle m'a
appris beaucoup de choses elle était
elle était vraiment résigné en fait de
la vie elle n'avait pas envie qu'on
s'attache à elle l avait pas envie de
s'attacher un humain non plus elle avait
mêlée mais pas le contact elle aimait
pas qu'on la regarde elle n'aimait pas
qu'on la touche
elle voulait être juste dans un coin
tout seul et qu'on la laisse tranquille
donc avec elle le travail ça n'a pas été
juste de tisser un lien là où les autres
s'étaient arrêtés mais c'était plutôt de
jeter complètement la corde et puis d'en
racheter une nouvelle lui apprendre les
nouvelles choses en fait elle avait eu
une seule mauvaise expérience dans sa
vie qu'on sait et elle avait décidé que
c'était la dernière elle avait plus
besoin d'humains elle voulait plus du
tout du moins dans sa vie à cause d'une
seule mauvaise expérience avec un seul
humain et pour elle c'était fini elle
m'a appris beaucoup de choses on sait à
prix mutuellement
en fait je lui montrer ce que je pouvais
lui offrir et elle me disait quand
c'était trop quand ce n'était pas assez
surtout quand c était trop en faire et
ce qui est fascinant avec c'est avec ces
animaux c'est que souvent on entend on
entend dire des gens j'ai l'impression
qu'il comprend tout en fait c'est vrai
c'est vraiment des aimants émotion c'est
à dire que ils comprennent notre stress
ils ressentent ils ressentent nos
douleurs ils ressentent notre joie est
sûre la joie il ya une petite
étude qui a été faite on se demandait
vous avez peut-être déjà vu déchets qui
sourit mais qui grognent pas juste il
sourit comme le maître rentrer à la
maison et on s'est demandé pourquoi ces
chiens souris est en fait est ce que ce
serait pas parce que nous humains entre
nous pour est peu de la joie on se
sourit mutuellement et comme le chien a
quand même une sacrée connexions dans
son cerveau il peut par mimétisme s'être
dit que lui aussi pour nous de trouver
de la joie il pouvait se mettre à nous
sourire
ce que je voulais dire c'est que on
entend on entend souvent dans dans notre
quotidien on entend des histoires
beaucoup avec des chiens on parle
surtout de bas de leur fidélité par
exemple de leur loyauté du courage ça et
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
d'une histoire d'un chien japonais qui
s'appelle hachiko il ya un film qui a
été fait sur lui
c'est un chien tous les matins il a mené
son maître à la gare d'où partait
travailler et tous les soirs et donné le
chercher et un soir c'est une histoire
vraie son maître est pas rentré en fait
il a fait un infarctus au travail il est
décédé à son travail et pendant dix ans
le shérif rester devant la gare à
attendre que son maître viennent il
suivait pas les façons il voulait pas
manger ils voulaient pas suivre de la
famille de son maître et il est mort
deux dans cette gare est aujourd'hui à
une statue qui a été fait pour lui sa
place
donc ça pour dire que vraiment les
chiens on voulait voit partout on les
voit la télé on les voit dans les
magazines dans des journaux non mais en
fait le chiffre il n'y a pas il n'a pas
d'une part toujours été chiens et n'a
pas non plus toujours été avec nous à la
base vont vous le savez le chien c'était
un loup et on pense qui s'est retrouvé
dans l'eau dans le pat parce qu'ils
voulaient profiter des restes de
nourriture qu'on pouvait avoir
il avait compris que nous on avait des
commandes humain et que dans ces
campements du moins il y avait plein de
choses récupérer et nous aussi comme on
est opportuniste comme le chien on s'est
dit ah lui il peut nous être utile
alors on a créé par des croisements
vie du on a créé des deschiens mais à la
base
juste pour une utilité bien spécifique
on a créé des chiens pour nous aider à
la chasse on a créé des chiens pour nous
aider pour guider le troupeau pour
garder notre peau pour tuer n'aura aussi
on a créé des chefs vraiment pour une
utilité vous bien à elle et puis on
s'est rendu compte que finalement je ne
fais pas si désagréable d'avoir un
compagnon autre qu'un humain c'est dire
peut-être que peut-être qu'on peut avoir
une relation tous les deux et on a
découvert aussi qu'ils avaient un
quelque chose que nous on n'avait pas
c'était un flair incroyable et pour
leurs apprenants on court on était
capable de leur dire
trouve moi cette odeur et préviens moi
quand tu la vois enfin quand tu la sens
et avec ça on a pu faire des chiens de
détection de drogues de des chiens qui
sont les crises d'épilepsie à l'avancé
des chaînes qu'ils trouvent des
personnes disparues des choses comme ça
il ya une recherche qui est en cours sur
s'est pas encore où on n'a pas encore
les résultats mais ils recherchent
concours sur est ce que les chiens sont
capables de détecter des cellules
cancéreuses
donc quand même on a fait une bonne
avancée et grâce à eux ils nous ont
montré plein de choses sur la science
sur les limites de la génétique et c'est
quand même il voilà ce qu'ils ont
apporté à l'homme en grand et moi
personnellement parce que les chéris
m'ont apporté c'est qu'ils m'ont permis
en fait de deux m'épanouir et me ils
m'ont appris des choses sur moi que je
savais même pas
je n'étais pas capable avant de venir
comme ça devant vous est et vous parler
de mes filles je trouvais déjà je
trouvais ça inutile puisque ne disait
pas que quelqu'un pouvait avoir un
quelconque intérêt à mon temps de parler
de mes chiens et de ce qu'ils me font
vivre et puis en plus une complète
c'est-à-dire que quand je suis triste il
sourit ou quand quand je ne sais pas ils
m'apprennent ou quand quand je suis père
d'une montre le chemin
vraiment les chiens pour moi ça a été un
poème une étoile comme l'étoile du
berger et je suis pas la seule
j'entends partout autour de moi gens qui
me disent ah le chien quand même
il apporte un truc en plus dans des
maisons de retraite on voit des gens qui
viennent avec des chiens pour donner un
petit peu de joie aux résidents ou alors
des gens qui étaient un peu repliés sur
eux-mêmes qui voulait pas sortir qu'il y
avait je veux pas trop le contact avec
les gens ça arrive beaucoup savent
souvent on dit que les gens qui aiment
les chiens il aime forcément pas les
humeurs faut pas vrai moi j'aime pas
tous mais jean même quelques-uns et ces
gens là il faut ils sont dans leur petit
appartement ils veulent pas voir de
monde et puis un jour on leur met un
chien dans les pattes
bah là ils sont bien obligés de sortir
parce que le chien il a besoin de faire
ses besoins
aussi il a besoin de faire pipi ni la
main de fer kk et donc ils sont obligés
d'aller dehors est dehors et ben y'a des
gens il ya des gens aussi avec des
chiens niveau non plus ne voulait pas
rencontrer d'autres gens avec des chiens
et finalement ces gens là se croisent et
puis bon il salue juste parce que entre
entre amoureux des chiens c'est ce qui
se fait et ils apprennent à se connaître
alors qu'est ce que fait t'on chien pour
moi et ça fait rire parce que elle
qu'elle y est ce que c'est ça pires
bêtises ils apprennent vraiment à créer
un lien et finalement ils trouvent que
le contact c'est pas le contact avec
l'humain qui est dérangeant c'est le
contact avec certains mais que c'est pas
parce que le pain de dingue d'une
boulangerie est pas bon qu'on n'aime
plus les boulangeries et qu'on aime t-il
teinte
c'est juste qu'on va changer de
boulangerie tout est donc les gens ils
se rendent compte que ils peuvent
s'ouvrir au monde et ils sont pas
obligés d'avoir plus leur petit
appartement enfermé et alors on en a
déjà parlé tout à l'heure mais
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans une
société où on a de plus en plus de
technologies on communique de moins en
moins on est toujours sur nos téléphones
portables on préfère appeler des gens
plutôt que aller les voir ans
bret préfère leur envoyer des messages
on fait vraiment appel à plein de choses
mais on va plus voir les gens
alors est ce que finalement le chien
s'est pas c'est pas ça est ce que
l'animal la connexion entre l'homme et
l'animal est ce que ce serait pas
finalement une la clé pour avoir une
meilleure connexion entre l'homme et
l'homme
[Applaudissements]